- I just put business in perspective.
- Put things in perspective.
- Keep things in perspective.
- Keep perspective.
- Have a different perspective.
- Hello, Believe Nation.
Today, we're going to talk about
how you can keep things in perspective.
And as always, guys as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really inspires you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it as well
so that other people can be inspired.
When you write it down, it's
much more likely to sink in
for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(uplifting music)
- When you have a down time,
like something didn't
work the way you want,
what do you do to get
back on that positiveness?
- I talk to the mountain.
I have a mountain next to my home
that is called Rochers de Naye.
It goes up to two, it's very low.
It goes up to 2400 or 2500 meters.
Or I talk to the Dents de Midi,
which is 4000 meters which is a little bit
further away from my home.
Which I see every morning.
I see those two mountains.
And I say to these two mountains,
Mountains, I have a problem,
but when I look at you,
you are 37 billion old.
(laughs)
And I'm a little guy here
with a little problem.
Can you help me?
They will say come on.
Look what we have already
seen in so many years.
Your problem is a nano-problem.
Come on, get up.
- Just get up, do it.
- That's it.
- My question is, I'm an
entrepreneur, it's very great,
but not all days are great in a company.
So what are your tips and
tricks for tough days?
- I think there's massive
confusion around entrepreneurship.
Entrepreneurship sucks.
I mean it's lonely, it's high risk.
I mean I can't live without it.
But it's like a bad boyfriend
or girlfriend, right.
There's a ton of bad days
being an entrepreneur.
Not to mention 98% of
entrepreneurial ventures
are going to fail.
So there's going to be a
really bad (bleeped) day
in your future.
(crowd laughs)
Um, you know, hopefully not for you.
Um, or any of you.
And you know, for me,
I think this is a very personal question.
I think it's how you're wired.
I'm so all-in entrepreneur
I prefer the pain.
I think one of the reasons
I love the Jets so much
is because they bring me so much pain.
You know, I love the climb.
To me, the set back is exciting.
I love when something goes wrong.
It's where I shine the most.
But that's not for everybody, right.
It can be very difficult.
And when you start affecting your life
and your loved ones and all other things,
it can get real nasty.
To me, the way I handle things
even on the few rare days
when I really struggle,
I take a real step back and make pretend
that somebody called me and told me
that my mother or daughter were killed.
And I know that's very
dark and I apologize,
but it's really what I do.
I literally am able to at my
deepest, most struggling moment
within business take a step back
and remind myself that I
could make a drillion dollars
tomorrow on bitcoin and
if something bad happen
to the people I love the most
that it would mean nothing.
And very consistently
rewires me very quickly.
I just put business in perspective.
At the end of the day, it's money...
For me, it's not really
money, it's my legacy.
So I get hurt by it a little bit more.
You know, I put it in
perspective, it's money.
And you know what, up
until I had a daughter,
even while I was married,
up until when I had Mischa four years ago,
I secretly wanted to lose all my money.
I had this weird, twisted, dark fantasy
of losing everything just to rise again
like a Phoenix and remind you (bleeped).
- Do you feel underrated as a rapper?
- Not as of lately.
Like which is crazy.
For a long time man,
for years, I was pissed.
So a song on the album called Buried Alive
is about that exact thing.
You know, it's about me kind of going
well how come he gets
the so and so cosigner,
how come he gets that or
how come they get that.
I can tour the world.
I can sell out shows.
I got fans, I got this.
What the (bleep) man, like being angry.
You know, I had a friend tell me,
she basically said those same people
who had the cosigns and have
the this and have the looks
are the same people are going
how come I ain't got fans like this then
and how come I can't tour on my own.
How come I can't this?
Like what the (bleep).
So it kind of put things
in perspective for me
and let me go, okay, I don't have it yet,
but if I keep fighting
and I keep working hard
and I keep staying on this path,
it's going to happen.
You know, and as of late
within the last few months man,
just from releasing the
singles and the music videos
and like this solid body of work,
I've truly began to get what I deserve.
- 13 years ago, you were
completely bust, gone.
No money, you had five
pounds, you know seven dollars
left in your hand.
You used it for a taxi
back to your parents.
And your career in the record business
had just come to sudden, shuddering halt.
And here you are 13 years later,
you're worth hundreds
of millions of dollars,
life's taken a huge turn up,
but I get the sense with you
that what happen to you 13
years ago still defines you now.
- Yeah, I mean it wasn't
the best of times,
but then again when I look back on it,
it wasn't the worst of times.
You know, because I think
particularly here in Hollywood,
where most people get it wrong
is they're afraid of
losing what they've got.
They're just terrified
of losing their fame,
as you said, power, money.
But actually once you've lost it,
you can always get it back again.
I mean it's not the end of the world.
I mean being ill is worse.
So because I've actually faced
one of most people's worst
fears and recovered from it,
it's not as bad as you think.
You know, I didn't lose my confidence.
My friends were still my friends.
I've lived with my parents.
And I just saw it as a challenge
that I've got to get myself
back on my feet again.
- What advice did your
parents give you there?
- Honest to god, they
were just cool about it.
You know, they were parents.
They just, you know,
want to look after me,
lived with them for a while.
My dad lent me some money to pay the bank.
Then, eventually I managed
to pay my Dad back.
You know, it was what any parent would do.
But like I said, it wasn't
the worst time of my life.
Actually, when I look back
on it now, I still smile,
because I bought this beat
up old British sports car,
worked 18 hours a day and
I was so determined, Piers,
just to get it right this time.
Cause I knew I'd got it wrong.
So now, I find it much
easier to deal with things.
- If that wasn't the worst
time of your life, what was?
- Well, when my Dad died was
the worst time of my life.
As you know, you and I discussed that.
That you know, like getting
ill, losing a parent,
or losing somebody close to you,
that's the worst thing that
could ever happen in your life.
In all the things that I worry about now,
it's just trivial.
I mean even the whole kind
of Idol, X-Factor thing,
I laugh about it because it's
such a high class problem.
My show is better than your show.
It's like we both got a show.
(laughs)
I mean what's the problem.
- It's a bit like Colin
Firth and Hugh Grant
in the fountain in Bridget Jones fighting.
- Exactly, over what?
I mean the fact that we're
here and we can do this,
it's fantastic.
- Before every one of my debates,
I did something to keep
things in perspective.
To keep myself grounded.
At the top of a sheet of paper
that was always placed on the podium
so we could make notes during the debate,
just before the debate kicked off,
I wrote at the top one word, dad.
I also drew a small image of the Sun.
And throughout the debate
when I glanced down
at that paper to look at
my notes that I had taken,
I was reminded of my father's fearlessness
in fighting for what
he believed was right.
And the Sun that reminded me
of course of that familiar scripture,
let your light so shine.
Win or lose that debate,
I hoped that I would never do anything
that would dishonor or discredit
the things I hold most dear.
Now during your life,
you're going to encounter circumstances
that make you sweat.
For many of you, the exams
and tests won't be over
when you graduate.
And you're all going to stand at podiums,
stand in front of a boss to ask for raise,
or work on some critical project
in your employment that
will make a big difference
in your life.
At moments like those,
perspective is a very powerful friend.
You can welcome perspective
through preparatory prayer
by considering the blessings of the temple
or by simply glancing at your CTR ring.
Find ways to keep your
life in perspective.
- When I was 20, I worked for this,
I grew up in Malvern in New York,
I worked for the sanitation department.
I was a garbage man.
- You were a garbage man?
- I was a garbage man.
I worked the back of the
truck, 22 square blocks.
That's hard.
Doing movies is, there's
nothing that we do
in the movies that's hard.
- I used to deliver for United
Parcel Service on a truck.
That was hard.
- Yeah.
- This is a joke.
- People always say why do you spend
so much time preparing and everything,
cause there's a bunch
of other guys out there
that would want my job
and I'm not going to do
anything to mess it up.
- That's right.
- Keep things in perspective.
I know we all say it,
but really you have to
keep reinforcing it.
You know all of, everyone
in this audience,
you know knock on wood,
you're going to do just fine.
You're going to have
your four bedroom house.
You're going to have your
car with power windows.
You'll be able to go to
Seaworld whenever you want to.
But along that way, there are
going to be ups and downs.
And actually those ups and
downs then to happen a lot
when you go to transition points.
When you're entering the work force,
you're entering some type
of new phase in your life.
And you just always have to keep on
kind of the long term game, the end game.
And you know, I'll tell you myself,
I've gone through fairly dramatic ones
right when I was out of the gate.
You know when I was, this was 1998,
I had just graduated.
I was a few months older
than most of you all.
And some computer magazine
had seen something I had done
and they wrote this neat profile about me.
They called it Future So Bright
and I saw that magazine,
I was very proud of it.
I was like, oh look, I'm set.
I have this career ahead of me.
I'm already profiled in a magazine.
And frankly, I got kind of into myself.
And it's okay, you can
enjoy your successes,
but I didn't have any perspective.
And frankly, it was a
dangerous thing to have happen.
And to really put things in perspective,
and I'm happy it did happen,
two months later I had
kind of switched jobs
and you know higher salary.
I thought I was on the fast track.
And I had a new boss and on
the first three days of work,
he spent an hour just
completely castigating me.
Essentially telling me that
I was not worth his time.
That I was incompetent as
far as he was concerned.
And so you can imagine, like a lot of you,
successful my whole life,
fancy degrees from fancy universities,
two months ago I was
profiled in a magazine
and then now, all of sudden,
not even 23 years old,
I was back in a hotel room in
the middle of nowhere crying.
Not knowing what I was
going to do with my life.
Convinced that it was all
the end of everything,
everything was for not.
And you know, so you get through them,
you wake up in the morning,
things look a little bit better.
A week later, things look a little better.
You start circulating your resume around.
I did find another job two months later.
And it's okay.
And the one thing I want to stress,
because I've gone through ups and downs
and you only have one
perspective for your own life,
but I suspect many of you all
are going to have higher ups than I've had
and many of you all are
going to have lower downs.
And I worry about that some times.
The ones of you that have higher ups,
just keep them in perspective.
And it's inevitable.
Some of you are going to race ahead
and be so successful that no
of us can imagine it right now.
But keep them in perspective.
Enjoy the successes,
but when your ego starts
a little bit large,
keep in mind the Sun
will supernova one day,
the galaxies will collide.
We are these small little
mammals on this small planet.
Or you know, there's 100, 200
billion stars in the galaxy,
in just our galaxy alone.
And just have peace in the little success.
And when you have a hard time,
and you will and some will
go through painful periods,
you might stumble and start
your first few times out the gate.
Also keep in perspective
that those stresses,
put them in perspective of the universe.
They are small.
They are going to be things
that you'll be able to
laugh about, talk about,
attend 15 years from now or
hopefully 10-15 days from then.
- Keep perspective.
And that's the hardest
thing to tell somebody
when they are going through a hard time,
because you know it's so easy to say
well you don't understand
me or this is so hard
or this is the worst time in my life.
And some of that might feel true.
And it might be true.
It might be one of the most
difficult, trying times
of your life.
And all we can say is keep perspective.
We can't say keep perspective,
other than just say there
have been good times.
Remember them.
Don't cut loose of those
good times in your memories,
just because now your
focus is on the dark times.
Remember those times that were better.
Remember those times in which
you did connect with others,
that you did create,
that you did take action.
And remember also your strength,
because it's so easy when times are dark
to just focus on all the things
that you're doing to screw it up.
Or all the things that people are doing
to mess with your life,
and you forget the incredible
power that you have.
I mean it is an amazing miracle,
if you're looking for the miracle,
you already got it.
That miracle that you've
been given the power of,
choice and will to direct
your own attention each day,
to direct your own attitude each day,
to direct your own actions each day,
to direct your own affections
and emotions out into the world.
That you control those things.
That you can move those things.
That you can shape those things.
That's the miracle.
You are the miracle.
You've been waiting for
something to show up and change
and I just say you've
already been given the gift.
Now, you have to activate it.
So when it's difficult,
keep perspective on the fact
that there have been good times,
there will be more good times,
even if you are struggling personally,
you still have that great freedom
that has been given to us,
and that choice and gift of free will
to start directing yourself.
- I mean obviously you can't
come on a show like this
without the mention of the
wanking in the toilet thing.
(crowd laughs)
- Which wanking in the
toilet thing? Which one?
- The arrest.
- Oh, of course. That one.
- Yeah, the one we've heard about.
(crowd laughs)
- The time I got caught you mean.
(crowd applause)
- See, this is the thing.
The way you talk about it is
your fantastic, sort of
unapologetic about it.
And you didn't go into hiding.
You didn't sort of, you
know draw the curtains.
Was it the next night, you
were out in a restaurant
in LA having dinner.
- Absolutely.
Well, I mean what's to apologize for.
You know, I'm a gay man.
At the time, I was like 36 years old.
If I'm perfectly honest,
if I'm perfectly, perfectly honest,
outside of my career, I've
had a terrible run of luck
that started about 10 years ago.
I've watched a partner die.
I've watched my mother die.
Just after that, I went
to see a back surgeon
who told me if I didn't
have two vertebrae removed
within the next six months to a year
that I could be paralyzed.
So you just learn to have
a different perspective.
I don't give a toss if people
have real problem with me,
you know...
(crowd applause)
I have a different perspective on life.
I lost a lot of great things,
but I still have a lot
of incredible things.
And the press doesn't
really enter into it.
- I want my daughter to grow up thinking
that the phrase working woman sounds
as odd and superficial and forced
as the phrase working man.
My husband is my greatest
source of motivation.
- She always has it in her to accomplish
whatever she puts her mind to.
- He's the person I lean on the most.
- I always tell Ivanka don't worry
about the things you can't control.
Just worry about how you react to
and deal with the circumstances
and situations at hand.
- In the moments of
highest anxiety for me,
I will think about Jared and the kids
and realize that no matter
how poorly I perform,
I will come home that night
and my kids will not love me any less.
And my husband will love me just as much.
Maybe even a little bit more,
because he'll know I need it.
- I'm still waiting to see the time
that she doesn't perform very well.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I love to know what did
you think of this video.
What lesson did you learn that
you love the most about this?
How do you keep things in
perspective for yourself?
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Takosha Swan.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.